the slow horses
not typical MI5
what's going on ex-service agent
founderton heart failure was in a 60s
smoke drank
oh God look at me yeah I'm in my Prime
he left a note on his phone
cicada
Russian sleeper agents embedded in
British Society
it's been reactivated more people are
gonna die if you uncovered the trail
that quickly
it couldn't have been that well hidden
thanks
[Music]
ma'am I do not need to slow horses
digging around the past
this feels too suspicious what does that
actually mean there's more to it
well has been an alert it's a Triton
right at the top he has unfinished
business
thousands of people they're gonna die
sometimes the only way to work out why a
trap has been set
is to walk into it
[Music]
I am Gathering the greatest from every
world
opens above
the real war is coming
I Risk Everything
all the president the time has come the
child is with her mother bring them to
me dead or alive
lost thing my dad asked me to do was
take the knife to his room first we need
to go to the Land of the Dead
can't bring people back from the dead
you have to try
what if we don't come back and we want
to die doing something important
that's real our daughter is in danger
the magisterium won her dead
you know who they say she is
far beyond your Rebellion
something changed
everything was in Balance but now the
world is dying
it hurts when we're apart
the greatest love
is the one that you can't live without
one that you're prepared to die for
ever
by turning back
the authority
one should be afraid of what the
authority has no power over us
we are free
[Applause]
[Music]
hope
we'll Spark
in darkness
something very big
and very dangerous is headed our way
immortus it's real and it's coming
we are wandering into the literal end of
days as we speak
I think he's serious
project it's the pursuit of immortality
have you ever wondered why you've looked
exactly the same for decades
[Music]
they gave you longevity that's it it's
all over for you love
we have to stop this before it's too
late
what do you saying do you want to go and
save some worlds we are heroes are we
not
ah fine
this is code red
stop this we have to confront our past
[Music]
we're gonna have to go back to where
this all began
[Music]
holy [ __ ] we're doomed at least you got
to have an orgasm before you die
[Music]
thank you
and the word for today is success
success success success success
unfortunately Gustav you're two years
later in your payment due to a lack of
success wrong way son
what are your fellow co-workers has put
all our lives at risk you're the one
Harbor and The Fugitive we can't be
going to jail let me tell you something
I visit you I don't go there I'm out
damn no car would stand a chance against
this thing Chicago get it together
they've got bed bugs a Toyota go out of
business soon RTO will be RT no more
no cold man is here let me get a Africa
nobody in the hell drinks this apricot
okay I don't even know how you've seen
that I had it in the back
she looks crazy she's skipping and it
makes her happy
we are heading into uncharted waters
we're in the nine volt battery it's
happening over there this don't sound
like you got what but it's not it's not
amazing
I vow to swim by your side
of Tampa I don't think she won a team
she wanted Dr to get her back blown out
I'ma come over there
he's gonna get out the car okay
[Music]
is
sounds like you're just sleepwalking
this has never happened before can be
caused by sleep deprivation stress
come on
you know
what is this
how am I dreaming
it's a dream
hey Dave here tell me the year
it's 1815
. we just heard a lot of screaming
is everything okay in there
how long was I gone less than a minute
not even seconds
it felt like I was gone for an hour
I know how this sounds
am I crazy surprise
[Music]
not crazy
whatever this is
it's real
[Music]
this holds a clue to a treasure of
utmost importance
I thought about destroying it a million
times
look at this
in order to prevent it falling into the
wrong hands
oh my God
so we're talking like an honest to God
treasure map
yeah
where did you get that necklace it was
my dad's
he died when I was a baby
what is it
the symbol on your necklace I know
do everything you know about your dad is
alive
how it leads to an important treasure
and searching for it is dangerous I know
it is
this is cooler than any room on any
episode of cribs I've ever seen Ben
Franklin glasses oh my God I want that
Relic
everything I thought I knew about my dad
my whole family for that matter is
crazy riddle that can only be solved by
finding this treasure
no one
[Music]
what's uh what's your clue I would love
to love to help out
welcome to the CIA
o 10 minutes but you're a very busy man
I get it you're running the whole
operation you mean how long I've been
working here about two days
the hell is this every letter is from
someone threatening to expose classified
information if we don't help them you're
the lawyer figure it out
I'm playful with it yeah basically
do your business get out I'm Owen
Hendricks from the CIA we got your
letter have you made any new friends or
overthrown any foreign governments
unbreakable you following
you know bullets go through metal right
yeah
congratulations you're being followed by
the entire United Nations
is the hood really necessary no you
under control no matter what it takes
seriously
panic attack oh I've been having one
continuously since 2019. you get used to
it
you're gonna need it is there a problem
[Music]
higher stakes be more challenging but
the bottom line is
falling on his face I'm 24 years old I'm
supposed to make mistakes take big
swings how about a martini how about a
white cloth
this need to jump into the deep end to
prove yourself over and over again it's
unhealthy
I think it's ambitious
I am actually just a lawyer
I'd like to think that I'm good at what
I do what you are is lucky
you'd be Mrs Dutton I would
seems we're neighbors I've acquired the
Stratford Ranch
well this is the Yellow Stone
and you have no rights here
Jacob you can't start a range War range
Wars already started
how much land do you want
I want the whole valley
either we take this fight to them or
it's coming us
men kill quick with a bullet or a noose
with their fight is with me and I kill
much slower
this is absolutely Wild
you're a hunter you're famous
foreign
tell the world what happens when they
cross me
greed would be the thing that kills us
off
did you own a Rainwater
come with me
you know God Jacob daughter
you attack my family it's gonna be the
last thing you ever do
foreign
[Music]
I've been practical I make one romantic
decision and it bit me in the ass are
you talking about work or Gabrielle
Paris oh
I just need to know are you on my team
or not I was beginning to wonder if
you're joining us at all I'm so in on
team whenever this company's called do
they know that you're pulling double
duty oh God no the CNB wants to see you
in the office right away she really mad
how fish I will who can translate this
not choosing is still choosing even not
choosing has consequences so it's still
a choice but how do we know we're making
the right one
[Music]
this is the hardest decision I have ever
had to make
so Cooper
where's your head at
you changed my life
it's not either or are we really here to
just love one person
we always talk about work-life balance
and right now I am all about life
oh you know I love when the story starts
like that
[Music]
don't take this time for granted you
guys for sure
[Music]
I'm so nervous
[Music]
are you all right
just some existential angst that is so
American
maybe the pressure is not worth it it's
definitely worth it it's your dream
sure for being a friend
travel down the road and Back Again
Golden Girls
Golden Girls never mind
[Music]
I can only imagine what's going on in
your head right now
foreign
then why are they chasing you
a group of hard-line Russians
formed a plan to preserve the USSR use a
nuclear strike to create chaos the
weapon has been built and it is on the
move
the U.S can't go anywhere near this we
don't have any wiggle room to make
mistakes if you don't come in you will
be recalled I come in now a whole lot of
people are gonna die
you're about to cross the line and there
may be no going back because I'm trying
to do the right thing
there's never just about a nuke this is
about starting a World War
someone was playing the dirty things
should Escape we love to eliminate
Jacqueline
Jack every second man is
Jack if you've got a plan the time is
now
I want Jack Ryan in custody immediately
so what are the odds this is a one-way
trip 80 90 that's my last fight won't be
in coach
foreign
I'm getting married
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Hollywood has come a calling they want
to make unfinished business into a movie
our Carefree College days on full
display I love it that book caused a lot
of drama get your popcorn ready
[Music]
you need to change the scenery so come
on the sequence wedding it's guaranteed
to put a smile on your face
[Music]
you need to find something
redefine your purpose I thought you
found your purpose with that perfume
commercial always in my playbook always
in my playbook
we all make mistakes man you gotta live
with the consequence I know what it's
like to be a tired overworked exhausted
mom wait don't you have like three
nannies it takes a village
[Music]
life doesn't always go the way we expect
because if we're lucky we end up where
we're supposed to
[Music]
we're actually really looking forward to
some has been a lifetime yes we are are
you two gonna have sex what's sex a
really yummy dessert then can I have sex
okay
you know who I want to play me oh Beyond
get your coins together brother
[Music]
Stay With Me
[Music]
Stay With Me
Stay With Me
all beginnings
[Applause]